the Joe Rogan experience reality
television is a very strange animal yeah
because it's not reality you know a lot
of times at least and one of the things
I think that's really exciting about
those shows like life below zero and
your situation in particular was that
there's only so much of that you can
fake I mean just the actual undisputable
reality of your existence is so
fascinating you have this tiny little
[ __ ] house that you built yourself on
a lake and then wolves are trying to
kill you like that [ __ ] is real
you don't mean I mean and you're out
there walking in the snow all you have
is like a rifle and some snow shoes and
a backpack that's as real as is humanly
possible and anything that they [ __ ]
with there it's like so what because the
the the scene itself is so crazy like
just you know your life I always feel
like that yeah there's no need to
[ __ ] yeah why do people think they
need to [ __ ] and it's not just
reality TV but in general I mean come on
it's in politics and everything yeah
just being straightforward and honest
can get you a long ways but a lot of
people think for some reason that it's
better to [ __ ] you why do you think
that is because in the short term it can
work for some people it even seems to
work for quite a while I mean come on
talking about the president yeah you can
go but I don't know I mean to me how do
you feel inside about yourself if you're
making some false story up about
yourself yeah right yeah there's
something about it too that when someone
gets caught like that Jesse small a guy
well you got am I saying it wrong no is
that juicy smooth eh is it just Jesse
smaller yes boy do you know he is no
good for you I should not even tell you
you don't need to know this nonsense no
I'm trying to get up-to-date it's a guy
who was an actor on the show Empire he
was actually in one of the alien movies
too he was in which one was he in he was
in the one with
it was a good one he was in a good one
he was one of the people on a ship
anyway who's in one of the more recent
alien movies
well the Mighty Ducks to a parent well
there you go he's been a bunch of [ __ ]
anyway he's an actor and he made up a
story allegedly seems like you made it
up of getting beat up by these white
supremacist with Trump hats on Magga
hats on they put a noose around his neck
and he walked into the hotel with a new
still around his neck and told the whole
story well he didn't bother taking the
noose off of his neck which is like
everybody's like what we--what like
everybody that heard the story it's such
a badly concocted story everybody that
heard the story was like what the [ __ ]
and then the two guys that he got to
rough him up he got these two guys to
rough him up and then they came out and
I was [ __ ] this guy paid us and then
the Chicago Police Department is they're
prosecuting him they're trying to get
him to pay for their investigation
there's lawsuits and he still it's it's
it's the most obviously fake story ever
and it's coming out of a guy who is a
really successful actor so it's so crazy
it's this you know race racial hate this
hate crime story that this guy concocted
for attention apparently you know the
thought is that he wasn't happy with his
role on Empire or what but it was a huge
national story wherever cuz everybody
knew kind of right away that it was fake
everybody's like wait wise he's got the
noose around his neck and he was holding
a Subway sandwich he went to a subway so
he still had the sandwich right somebody
smacked him in the head a couple of
times and he had noose around his neck
he's telling this crazy store and he
wants to hold press conferences he said
he was the black Tupac or the gay to POC
he called himself sorry it was just
complete nonsense and there's something
about him talking telling his story
where you know it's [ __ ] and you're
like what are you doing like what is
this it's such it's so compelling and
you see some
lie like that about some crazy wacky
made-up story it's so compelling it's
like because you know like I when I was
a little kid I was live out [ __ ] I'd
make stuff up you know every little kid
will tell you a lie and I remember
thinking this guy never stopped like he
like lied like when he was a little kid
yeah and just kept lying that happens
some people Cass yeah yes that's the
dangerous thing about lying oh yeah if
you lie enough I think some people
actually start believing it oh for sure
yeah yeah yeah this is psychosis
involved for sure yeah some people when
they lie about their past and you know
like the one that weirder once is like
when guys get caught with stolen valor
like they have a crazy lie made-up story
about their military history and war
record and that happened with somebody
in reality TV that was working with Cody
Lundin wasn't there somebody working
with him
dual survivor something tape oh one of
his one of his guys was was a stolen
valor guy me I shouldn't say I don't
know never watch the show but I if I
remember right I heard that he's a weird
one huh that guy just walking around
barefoot with his disgusting feet I like
to go barefoot yeah but his feet it
looked like the monsters feet would show
him like it'd be like a thing like a
badge of courage which show these
gigantic calloused feet like what he
didn't have any shoes cuz he everywhere
he walked and walked barefoot so his the
bottom of his feet was like the top of
this table like this hard crusty and
[ __ ] look at that look at that guy
shoot his foot oh look at that here's
the thing man mine don't get like that
even when I go out there in the [ __ ]
desert constantly is that that's not his
foot dude that's a little kid's foot
really it says Cody's flip-flops I was
like a flip-flop that he made he made it
for someone yeah okay yeah there's
something about walking around barefoot
that seems really [ __ ] gross I love
it
in the summer it's the first thing I
want to do is get my shoes off yeah oh
yeah I climb up the mountains barefoot
until I get to where the rocks are you
know anyway oh yeah I've walked like the
60 miles from the road to my camp
two-thirds of the way barefoot really
yeah got a
blister on my foot after about 20 miles
and took my shoe off and I realized hey
the foot without a shoe feels a lot
better than one with a shoe so I took
them both off once the rest of the way
oh yeah I'm big into walking barefoot
[Applause]